I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.
THANK YOU.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: SO THERE ARE PEOPLE,
NOT JUST A FEW PEOPLE BUT QUITE
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE SITTING IN
SOLITARY CONFINEMENT IN THE D.C.
JAIL CHARGED WITH TRESPASSING.
YET TONY FAUCI IS NOT ONLY FREE,
UNINVESTIGATED BUT RUNNING
AROUND BASKING IN THE LOVE ON
CABLE TV SHOWS.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE?
POSSIBLY TONY FAUCI KNOWS HOW TO
USE THE MEDIA.
IF YOU WATCHED MSNBC LAST NIGHT,
YOU SAW THE SURREAL INTERVIEW HE
DID WITH JEB BUSH'S FORMER FLAK.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE.
AND AT CNN, THEY ASKED FAUCI WHY
HIS E-MAILS WERE REDACTED.
FAUCI LAUGHED IN HIS FACE.
>> AND E-MAIL EXCHANGE WITH YOU
AN FRANCIS COLLINS, IT SAID
CONSPIRACY THEORY GAVE MOMENTUM
AND THE IDEA OF THE LAB LEAK.
THE E-MAILS THAT I CAN SEE ON
THE SCREEN WAS ALL REDACTED WITH
YOU AND FRANCIS COLLINS.
DO YOU REMEMBER --
>> JOHN, THEY ONLY TALK ABOUT
10,000 E-MAILS FROM ME.
OF COURSE I REMEMBER.
I REMEMBER ALL 10,000 OF THEM.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
>> TO BE CLEAR, YOU'RE SAYING
YOU DON'T REMEMBER?
YOU CAN'T TELL US WHAT WAS IN
THE BODY --
>> I DON'T REMEMBER WHAT IS IN
THAT REDACTED.
BUT I MEAN, THE IDEA I THINK IS
QUITE FAR FETCHED THAT THE
CHINESE DELIBERATELY ENGINEERED
SOMETHING SO THAT THEY COULD
KILL THEMSELVES AS WELL AS OTHER
PEOPLE?
I THINK THAT IS A BIT FAR OUT.
>> IT WASN'T MUCH OF AN
INTERVIEW TO PUT IT MILDLY.
THAT'S TONY FAUCI'S OFFICIAL
RESPONSE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO SAY ANYTHING.
ON MSNBC HE WAS PRESSED HARDER
BY SOMEONE THAT IS SMART AND
FAUCI REFUSED TO DISCUSS WHETHER
CHINA MIGHT HAVE A MOTIVE TO
COVER UP A LAB LEAK.
>> YOU SAY IT'S IN CHINA'S
INTEREST.
WOULDN'T YOU IT'S IN THEIR
INTEREST TO HIDE IT IF THERE WAS
A LAB LEAK OR WORSE IF THEY WERE
DESIGNING SOMETHING IN THEIR LAB
SO THE WORLD, THAT AMERICA
DIDN'T KNOW THAT IT CAME OUT OF
THEIR OWN LAB?
WOULDN'T THEY WANT TO CONCEAL
THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, WILLIE, I DON'T
WANT TO BE SPECULATING ON
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
EVERY TIME I SAY THAT, YOU KNOW
IT WILL GET TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT
AND GO INTO THE TWITTER WORLD
LIKE CRAZY.
SO I'M GOING TO LEAVE THAT TO
OTHER PEOPLE.
NOT SURMISE AND GUESS WHO IS
INTERESTED.
IT'S NOT HELPFUL.
>> Tucker: MIRANDA DIVINE IS A
COLUMNIST FOR THE "NEW YORK
POST."
THANKS FOR COMING.
YOU KNOW, YOU HATE TO KEEP
GROUSING ABOUT THE MEDIA BECAUSE
IT DOES GET REPETITIVE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
MATTERS BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE VIRUS CAME FROM.
WE CAN'T PREVENT ANOTHER
PANDEMIC.
WE CAN PROBABLY SAVE LIVES IF WE
FIGURED THIS OUT.
AT WHAT POINT ARE WE GOING TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS?
WILL THE MEDIA DECIDE ENOUGH OF
THIS.
ANSWER THE FREAKING QUESTION.
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW IF THEY
EVER WILL.
ANTHONY FAUCI HAS BEEN CLEVER AT
SHAPING THE MEDIA, PARTICULARLY
ON THIS PANDEMIC STORY.
HE KNEW FROM DAY ONE THAT THERE
WERE REPUTABLE SCIENTISTS THAT
BELIEVED THAT THIS WAS A MANMADE
VIRUS.
HE ALSO KNEW THAT HE HAD BEEN
FUNDING GAIN OF FUNCTION, THE
FRANKENSTEIN RESEARCH TO MAKE
CORONAVIRUSES IN THE LAB TO GET
AROUND THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
BAN.
TONY FAUCI WAS THE WORLD'S
GREATEST FAN, GREATEST SUPPORTER
OF THE GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
MANY THOUGHT IT WAS TOO
DANGEROUS TO KEEP ON WITH.
THEY CONVINCED THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO LIFT THE BAN.
AND THEN TONY FAUCI TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THE NEW TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN THEIR EARLY
DAYS IN 2017 TO GO AND TELL THEM
THAT THERE WAS NOTHING
DANGEROUS.
THEY HAD DONE A REVIEW AND TO
LIFT THAT MORATORIUM.
HE IS -- IF THIS IS A LAB LEAK,
THAT IS WHY HE HAS A VESTED
INTEREST.
THE LAST THINGS HE WANTS IS FOR
ANYBODY IN THE MEDIA TO COME
CLOSE TO SAYING IF THIS IS A LAB
LEAK, ARE YOU RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE RESEARCH THAT RESULTED IN
THAT LAB LEAK?
HE DOESN'T WANT THAT.
THE OTHER PERSON THAT IS VERY
CONFLICTED IS THE MAN WHOSE SUB
AGENCY IN NEW YORK, THE NIH
THROUGH TONY FAUCI WAS FUNDING,
PETER DASZEK AND LIKE FAUCI,
HE'S VERY POWERFUL IN TERMS OF
SHARING THE NARRATIVE.
YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT THE LANCET
ARTICLE THAT HE ENGINEERED.
HE WAS THE ONLY AMERICAN PERSON
ON THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
INVESTIGATION WHITE WASH INTO
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE LAB.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THIS -- I HOPE THAT YOU KEEP
PUSHING AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN, MIRANDA, YOU AND A FEW
OTHERS TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
IT HAS PROFOUND CONSEQUENCES NOT
JUST FOR UNDERSTANDING OUR PAST
BUT FOR THE FUTURE.